[Music]
there's a planet on the other side of
the Ring a group of Berta refugees has
claimed it as their home a UN ship was
sent to control the situation the
mission did not go as planned I need to
know what is really going on over there
I saw the news you're heading to the
ring we're going to make sure it's a
benefit is another eros evacuate the
betters and get the hell out of there
welcome to new terror
[Music]
that's proto molecule tech the artifacts
on this planet are waking off Jesus
Christ
they were foolish to think they could
invest there
we need to see if we can figure out how
to turn off what I just turned on
you're inside that recession would you
see a bunch of people killing each other
to control something they didn't even
understand there is no version of this
where we leave these squatters and
murderers in possession of this planet
this place is our only hope for not
giving it up
[Music]
[Applause]
I open those gates so I'm responsible if
anything comes through
we won't answer for what we've done
doesn't give you the right to play
executioner
I'd say the battle lines have been drawn
someday I think you and I gonna wind up
bloody I'm free right now
[Music]
[Music]